bienvenidos otra vez bienvenidos otra
vez a este a este vídeo bueno a este
vídeo pero a estar escuchando que bueno
recordemos que sabemos ya sobre
identidades trigonométricas showkat o
ashoka todas en un cateto opuesto
hipotenusa coseno cateto adyacente
hipotenusa tangente cateto opuesto
cateto adyacente y de hecho bueno en la
definición del círculo unitario utiliza
directamente soca tohá es una manera
fácil de recordar las identidades
trigonométricas es cierto nos ayuda
bastante ahora que sabemos sabemos que
el
beteta es igual a karate todo puesto
sobre hipotenusa cierto y ahora coseno
de teta es igual a cateto adyacente
sobre hipotenusa y ahora tangente de
teta esto a tangente de teta es igual a
cateto opuesto sobre cateto adyacente y
bueno dibujemos eso con un triángulo
rectángulo podríamos hacerlo también con
el círculo unitario también tendría
sentido veamos si podemos encontrar una
relación entre el seno el coste en la
tangente
aquí tenemos ya mi triángulo rectángulo
su ángulo recto y acá está teta
esta es la hipotenusa h este es lado
opuesto el opuesto a teta y acá tenemos
el lado adyacente ahora bien que sabemos
de cómo se relacionan la hipotenusa
alkate todas diaz ente y el cateto
opuesto que sabemos que nos dice el
teorema de pitágoras nos dice que
de lado al cuadrado más este lado al
cuadrado es igual a la hipotenusa al
cuadrado cierto entonces lo voy a
escribir al cuadrado más o al cuadrado
es igual a h al cuadrado y bueno esta es
simplemente una ecuación si queremos
podríamos dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación por h al cuadrado y obtenemos
que obtenemos obtenemos al cuadrado
sobre h al cuadrado más o al cuadrado
sobre h al cuadrado es igual a uno
simplemente dividido entre h al cuadrado
luego yo podría reescribir esto como a
sobre h al cuadrado sobre h al cuadrado
más o sobre h al cuadrado o sobre h al
cuadrado es igual a 1 ahora te parecen
familiares estas dos claro que sí porque
porque las tenemos justamente acá guau
magia entonces aquí tenemos ésta es
sobre h
sobre h y o sobre h
simplemente podemos sustituir esto es
coseno de teta al cuadrado así es como
se escribe la anotación que se usa
podrías escribir el paréntesis y después
poner el cuadrado pero no ahora más esto
es seno de de tal cuadrado igual a 1 y
ahí tenemos nuestra primera identidad
trigonométricas así que como puedes ver
si sabes seno de teta es muy sencillo
calcular coste no detecta cierto así que
bueno simplemente resuelves esta
ecuación si yo sé que digamos seno de
teta es igual a un medio un medio
entonces cuánto vale el coste no de teta
bueno bien yo sé que el seno de teta es
un medio entonces digo coseno cuadrado
de teta coseno cuadrado de teta más más
un medio al cuadrado más un medio al
cuadrado es igual a 1 vamos bien aunque
entonces coseno cuadrado de teta más un
cuarto es igual a 1 por lo tanto
coseno cuadrado de teta es igual a tres
cuartos o costo de teta es la raíz
cuadrada de tres cuartos tomamos la raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados coste no de tete
es igual a raíz de tres sobre dos y
bueno quizás recuerdes de alguno de
algún vídeo pasado ahí ya tenemos la
primera identidad trigonométricas coseno
cuadro de t está más seno cuadrado de
teta es igual a 1
así que extendamos un poco jugamos un
poco con estas razones veamos si si hay
otras identidades y claro que las hay
aunque el secreto ha sido revelado
pantalla negra muy bien entonces sabemos
que el seno cuadrado de teta más el
coseno cuadrado de teta es igual a 1 y
bueno una cosa podríamos hacer aquí que
podríamos hacer es dividir por coseno
cuadrado de teta ambos lados de la
ecuación entonces entonces veamos qué
sucede coseno cuadrado detectan
dividimos aquí entre cos en un cuadrado
de tétricos en un cuadrado
y también acá entre entre coseno
cuadrado de teta y ahora bien qué es
seno cuadrado de tetas sobre coseno
cuadrado de teta eso es lo mismo que
seno de teta sobre coseno de t está todo
elevado al cuadrado cierto ahora bien
esto es más uno esto es uno igual a 1
sobre coseno dt tan elevado todo al
cuadrado porque 1 al cuadrado es 1
solamente lo re escribo y bueno seno de
tetas sobre coseno de teta es
simplemente la tangente de teta en caso
de que no se pasa eso piénsalo de esta
manera seno de teta es cateto opuestos
sobre hipotenusa cierto entonces ponemos
aquí opuesto sobre hipotenusa y cosenos
de teta es cateto adyacente sobre
hipotenusa adyacente sobre hipotenusa
por lo tanto esto es igual opuesto sobre
potter usa por hipotenusa sobre
adyacente la división de fracciones es
multiplicar por su recíproco cierto
entonces esto es lo que yo hice
igual a opuesto sobre adyacente opuesto
sobre adyacente
eso es seno de teta sobre coseno de teta
es igual a tangente de teta entonces se
nos cuadrado detrás sobre coseno
cuadrados detalles simplemente tangente
cuadrado de teta más uno es igual a 1
sobre coseno de teta al cuadrado se me
hace bastante difícil pronunciarlo bueno
ahora voy a introducir una nueva razón
trigonométricas la cual es simplemente
uno sobre coseno dt tan lo cual es igual
a la secante de teta y solamente es otra
razón la secante de teta en lugar de ser
el adyacente sobre la hipotenusa es la
hipotenusa sobre el adyacente es
solamente uno sobre coseno no hay nada
especial aquí no hay nada como que te
diga su agua es solamente la secante por
lo tanto aquí tenemos secante cuadrada
de teta sé que inicialmente puede ser un
poco confuso porque estoy aquí metiendo
nuevos términos pero una vez que juegues
con las razones y te familiarices la
vida será tendrá mucho más sentido así
que puedes visualizar esto como una
identidad trígono meta
bueno de hecho no recuerdo si ya lo hice
en otro vídeo también esto lo puedes
visualizar como una identidad
trigonométricas aunque es casi por
definición y luego por supuesto podría
ser en caso de que no lo haya yo he
hecho ya ahora sabes qué seno de tetas
sobrecoste no de teta es igual a
tangente de teta y bueno esto esto está
aquí supongo que podrías ver esto como
la prueba de ello cierto
así que entre seguir introduciendo más
cosas sí sí es que es muy confuso
solamente ve mira el vídeo una y otra
vez
no olvides jamás el shock a toba eso es
muy importante y bueno ayayay otra vez
el secreto revelado entonces bueno
aunque hemos aprendido hasta ahora hemos
aprendido que el seno cuadrado de tamas
coseno cuadrado de teta es igual a 1
aprendimos que el seno sobre el coche no
es igual a la tangente a la tangente dt
tan aprendimos también
que la tangente cuadrada de teta
tangente cuadrada de teta más uno es
igual a secante de teta y de hecho
escribir esto por acá acá bueno se cante
de teta de dukes aquí es x al cuadrado
lo siento entonces secante de teta es
igual a 1 sobre coseno de teta
y bueno simplemente debes memorizar eso
ahora te estarás preguntando tal vez
bueno que que es uno sobre seno de theta
eso es la co se cante con secante de
tetas y se abrevian y tal vez te
preguntes bueno y que es uno sobre
tangente de teta eso eso es la co
tangente de teta ahora debo decir que
hay aquí al aquí hay algo que me
confunde porque uno sobre cocina de tres
y wallace y cante de teta pero uno sobre
seno de trata es igual a la co secante
de teta y parece como que como que son
opuestos porque porque uno sobre seno
tiene ese coste cante pero uno sobre
coseno no tiene es eco entonces como que
me confunde pero te puede ayudar a eso
para memorizar lo cierto y bueno veremos
otras identidades en otros vídeos